FEMA my name is Ralph Greco I'm a
producer I produced TV developing
independent films trying to work with
up-and-coming independent filmmakers and
actors and stuff to kind of build the
business in LA now for 15 years I do
love it like mainstream television
but I kind of gravitate more indie film
scene and kind of what courage does and
let me see the film perch interactive I
think it's a great venue for it's
actually I think kind of the before the
kind of you know ground zero for like
the new kind of my independent film
things business has changed a lot in the
last couple of years and I think right
now at least in LA I New York there's a
really kind of grassroots seen building
up around like independent filmmakers
independent producers making independent
films not low budgets to do
a lot of people that are not waiting for
permission are waiting to get dinner
made or you know for the big break to do
their work and get the work scene I
think that's like a huge kind of
movement that's starting to build and I
think it's important as many
professional people involved in that
because a lot of a lot of content out
there now and I think we need to do is
kind of build the communities of that
you know professional surprises up
content and stuff and prized above and
start building I'm really attractive
that I've always loved film I love
filmmaking it's all I've ever wanted to
do and I think our thing is working as a
professional is you kind of get
sidetracked by a job or who are you kind
of don't want you know you're making
money and you're successful and then you
don't really do the projects you want so
I think what these these kind of
functions and what Damon and Karen do or
is really important because it kind of
makes you know it brings people together
it's not your people sending off resumes
or writing blind emails you get certain
relationship
that's that's kind of thinking we should
go and that's what I'm trying to do a
turn read as many people depend
to kind of cream the professional edge
kind of mine I know